uh I don't understand how Amazon made  over 11 billion dollars in profit last  year and they paid zero in federal taxes  and at the same time New York was about  to offer them a three billion dollar  package including half a billion dollars  in direct incentives to locate their  second headquarters in New York or that  we have so many loopholes that have been  crafted by lobbyists to benefit  particular clients within a certain  industry we need to reshape Washington  we need to make it more transparent we  need to make sure that it serves the  people of this country and not only  people that can afford high-priced  lawyers or lobbyists and we do need to  go big on some of these things